San Francisco I'll be back Friday
December 8th and Saturday December 9th
at Cobbs Comedy Club it's the last stop
of the live and Alive tour for 2023 get
your tickets at Ryan sikler
docomo to make um you may have heard me
say this on my ymh episode but I am
starting a new podcast it's going to be
right here on this YouTube channel it's
called the way back it drops Thursday
January 4th and it will be a weekly pod
every Thursday moving forward after that
all right um it's a Nostalgia podcast
it's a short one too it's a quick hitter
no more than 30 minute episodes with
some of your favorite guests in comedy
and podcasting we already have a ton of
them recorded uh I'm very excited to do
this if you're a big fan of the crab
Feast if you're a big fan of the
Honeydew I know you're going to be a big
fan of this show um it's just something
I've always thought about you know and
the set is the back seat of that old
school station wagon facing traffic
looking that way all right it's the way
back cuz we're sitting in the way back
and we're looking back on things and uh
here's a fun teaser just to get you
excited about the idea check this out
it's the way back with Ryan sichler
right here on my YouTube channel every
Thursday beginning January
4th there is some of those memories of
childhood that are so fascinating bar
gave us his favorite porno because we
would put M8 one of my older brothers
used to fart in my mouth like I can't
wear a diaper be funny I'll spray fire
at my cousin I got puked on and her boob
popped outen someone's going to die
ecstasy like everything call it the
Chaser did not feel safe
holy yeah those were the days that was a
fun trip down memory
[Music]
lane
the Honeydew with Brian
[Music]
sickler welcome back to the Honeydew
y'all we are over here doing it in the
night pants Studios I am Ryan sichler
Ryan sikler Ryan cich on all your social
media and I'm going to start this
episode like I start every episode by
saying thank you thank you for your
support thank you for watching listening
um if you're new here if you've been
here I appreciate all of it make sure
you subscribe help out the show uh and
if you got to have more then I'm telling
you you got to check out the patreon
it's called the Honeydew with Y all it's
the same show with you all and there are
hundreds of the wildest episodes you've
ever heard in your life it's five bucks
a month not just for the month you get
the entire Library all right go check it
out and if you gotta have something else
to listen to then you got to check out
the crab feast all right it's my old
podcast it's still thriving out there
which blows me away so thank you feaster
Nation um I love seeing all the crab
Feast fans still rep the merch come to
the shows and stuff it was a great
podcast it's all the same comedians you
know and love from podcasting with
different stories it's free it's out
there now go subscribe to it it's Audio
Only it's a really fun
podcast um and if I am in town when
you're around come see me on tour
closing out the year cob in San
Francisco December 8th and 9th that's it
all right that's the business you guys
know what we're doing over here we're
highlighting the low lights always say
these are the stories behind the
storytellers I'm very excited to have
this guest on today first time here on
the Honeydew ladies and gentlemen Kevin
Ryan welcome to the Honeydew thank you
thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you for making time for us buddy
been wanting to do it for years thanks
for making time and I've all I I've been
on your show twice now I think we did a
zoom during the pandemic the first time
and I came to your beautiful [__]
Studio where Fresh Off back surgery
stepped out of the bathroom and almost
went right back into [__] back
Jesus you were like an old uncle that
came in oh watch that I was a liability
for sure I was aaint was still drying
I'm like I don't think the [__]
insurance policy's in effect yet sichler
is going to jam us up his L2 is [__]
fractured over um please before we begin
plug promote everything and anything you
would like uh are you garbage podcast
wherever you get Podcast um we're all
over the road the stay trashy tour it's
a mix of uh uh me and H foli to mix a
standup and you know we play a with the
crowd we each co- headline and then we
let the crowd ask their garbage
questions we [__] on them for a half
hour it's a good freaking time yeah
that's good so arug garbage.com for all
live shows social media social media
Kevin rri comedy on Instagram Twitter
and are you garbage on Instagram Twitter
and Tik Tok and everything yeah well
dude I'm still soak to have you here
thanks this is real First 48 Vibes dude
I feel like I'm in a [__]
interrogation dude that that door closes
and The Vibes
change it's good it's good but you're
like we're out there all laughing I'm in
here I'm like oh man they got me they
got they know something I don't know
like the box over here I picture one of
The Producers just picked up a Diet Coke
can that I was drinking earlier with a
pen and he's like we got them that's it
we got the bald one this is this is
where it ends dude this is this is where
you get me you're not [__] hadn't gone
well if you're on this show okay [__] is
not going well in your life if you're
doing this show sure um dude first of
all I want to talk to you about cuz I I
want to know about where you from before
we were just talking your last name's
Ryan I said what is that Iris you said
yeah but then you said your mom my mom's
a Sullivan and my stepdad's a Kelly so
it's like I dirty Shanty Irish Catholic
trash through and through and where are
you from here in the States from uh
Philadelphia originally mom's whole Mom
and Dad's whole family there
out of like the 150 people that are my
Aunts Uncles and cousins a handful of
all moved out for work or like the
military or something but everybody's
come back like I when I moved to New
York people are like we going all the
way to New
York 90 it's 90 minutes dude it's 90
minutes and like my mom had been to New
York like two times and now it's only
been like since I've been up there for a
decade she's come up twice it's like we
just don't it's a very blue collar
working family head down drink a lot on
the weekends and then weekdays and you
know it tends to become a problem for a
lot of people but uh we were living in
Philadelphia and then my dad was
uh construction it's all blue collar
right there's a couple teachers some
cops fire it's like [__] Angela's
Ashes dude it's like right it's it's as
stereotypical Irish Catholic trash as
you can get dude it's [__] there's a
couple a couple really smart people but
even then like I got a cousin he's so
smart and he's like covered in tattoo
like it's like even the Smart Ones are
still got under choices yeah yeah he's
got like all of his kids names tattooed
on his hands and you're like what are
you doing but um so it's like even that
and so we my dad was a steam fitter like
a HVAC guy worked his way through it's
all Union everybody's a union contractor
so like worked his way through the union
and started his own company made a
couple of bucks cuz my mom was one of
nine her dad was a cop and like there
was like 11 people living in like a TW
bedroom house in Kensington filled up
Kensington is now that neighborhood you
see where like all the crap all the dope
fiends are out on the street open air
drug Market that's where my that's where
the origin story of of Kevin where the
Ryan that's where it started dude that's
my whole family is from Kensington like
that's it it's like it's it's that that
is and there's so many of us and so many
we have a guy somebody you construction
you need a car you need this you need
tickets to an event you need parking
down there we know a cop call up you
know call up Steve Gallagher he'll
parking right around the back with the
whatever and like my cousin says we're
like the Kennedy without the money like
there's you know there's a h hundred of
us some died in a bad accident somewhere
along the way but um so my dad made a
couple of bus
and moved out like from the inner city
to like still in the city but on the
outskirts a little bit and then made a
little bit more money and got us into
the suburbs okay I guess when I was like
three or four or so and then uh he was
just not great with money it's like you
know he started doing the business
started doing well and I I guess he's
never ran a business so it's like there
was huge influxes of money that he was
like this is my money and you're like no
that's it's got to go to pay for the
materials and stuff you know what I mean
so like he would get new cars and then
like a uh a house up the mountains and
then like that was getting sold two
years later and then like the cars were
getting repoed in the middle of the
night like that real new money [__] like
no idea how to handle it and they got
divorced when I think I was I don't even
the first the only memory I have of them
together is them telling me they're
getting a divorce yeah it's the only
memory only memory you have your parents
to get
is them sitting you down to tell you
they it's over it's a WP we did it we we
tried the best we could do that's the
only thing I got dude I swear to God
nobody believe cuz that's like out of a
movie
like that's it terrible that's it dude
that's it and I remember they like sat
me down and I'm like real squirly and
kind of cold emotionally it's I keep it
all in no wonder
why kid had a rough
start you're [__] sliding with your
big wheel on her like listen kid it's a
WAP on this [__] it was they sat me down
and I remember being like we got to talk
to you where were you in a restaurant
were you at home where they didn't get
you to McDonald's and try to help you no
no and they wanted I have an older
brother and an older
sister and they wanted to separate us
cuz I I didn't really have an
understanding of it if I you know I
think I was four or whatever that was
divide and conquer bro yeah they were
like well let's get him out of the way
cuz he's not going to understand it oh
God you were first do you know that I
was first yeah so I well then I I I
called setup I knew so I was like why
the [__] aren't they here I said go I
want to talk to I was like we don't this
isn't right you don't sit me down both
of you something how old are you cuz
you're about four when you get to the
suburbs I'm four when we move to the sub
it's right it was right away they built
their dream
housee all built all you know like the
theory of like oh we're going to live
together this sounds like my [__]
family the business is PR my favorite
house and like my mom's still in that
house like she kept that house um as a
testament to her as a single mom she was
like I'm not my kids because we were in
such a good school district she's like
I'm not giving up this house like I
learned the I learned the term house
poor when we when I was like seven I'm
like can we get this she's like honey
we're house poor like all the money goes
to keeping you in this house and keeping
you in this school so we don't have to
go back to the open air drug
Market um so they were telling me and I
call I felt The Vibes weren't good and I
was like why aren't Danny and Sarah here
and my mom's like Oh we want to talk to
you I'm like no go get like so my dad's
like all right just [__] oh really
demanded it this is too weird what what
do we do we've never done this before be
able to do that too yeah so they brought
them down and they reacted horribly
because they were like
eight and nine or something like that so
they were like devasta my sister's like
hitting my dad you know it's like they
reacted how a normal and I was just like
it didn't I'm like I don't [__] care
and then my dad was like does anybody
want to come with me today and I was
like what the what are you nuts what
that mean like I don't I don't know I
guess like where you going you right now
you're going yeah he's like he was
leaving and he's like I guess he had
already move I don't know I don't really
remember but he was like does anybody
want to come with me today and we were
like I was like dude get the you're
gonna bring me out of this [__] dope
ass house with all my toys and [__] like
to go live in a [__] motel room for
three weeks I'm like no way dude I'm
like we're staying here um also it's
interesting that as young as you guys
are your parents didn't make that
decision and say you're going to stay
with Mom in this house so you stay he's
like sure uh step forward if you want to
come with me it was real like who's
going who's going to make a move you
know what I mean I was like I ain't
[__] going nowhere dude this
freezer's full of nuggets in here I
don't know where the [__] you're taking
me but we got it pretty kind of nuggets
from Kensington you know you know what
I'm saying kind of nugs got pretty made
in the shade in this cushy ass big house
in the BS um so then yeah and they they
they kept it together surface level do
you know the reason they divorced was it
just they didn't get along or was
there's some [__] going on you don't
have to share it yeah yeah I don't like
I tend to protect the innocent and a lot
of that's when I was like going over I'm
like what story is going to tell him
like well that kind of [__] throws
that guy under the bus that throws IR on
the bus that ain't great um but I
honestly don't truly know all of the
details and that's like another thing
about uh my family is like it's a don't
ass don't tell you know [__] repress
keep your head down just keep [__]
you got to get up and go to work that's
the only thing work go work go work it's
work it's work and then drink beers at
happy hour that's all my family did for
a long time and now as we get older and
like my brother my sister myself get a
little more you know are more
emotionally intelligent and stuff like
that we are having really good
conversations with with my mom that like
I never had in the past I was like um so
that's great um so your dad leaves
nobody goes with him nobody goes with
him and then what's your relationship
with him like from that point still good
does he stay close he stays close he
stayed like 10 minutes away maybe like
like he was in the area and did you go
to his place and stuff from time to time
yeah they had it split we like I I I you
know I have to give to him he was just
like you're not I'm not not seeing my
kids and he was great in my life all the
time so it was like Monday Tuesday was
with my mom Wednesday Thursday was with
my dad and then Friday Saturday Sunday
would flip-flop every week bro that's
that's the 223 I have with my daughter
right now that's what I have right now
with my daughter's mother my 223
schedule I I really it didn't shake me
really at all it was close it was and
she's known that from even she's one
when we split so she didn't have to be
like hey call everybody in for this
[__] [__] meeting yeah she's it's
not it's what she's know what she knows
and it's also at the same time like like
I said I didn't know them together right
so like my only my first memory of them
is going this is what we're doing right
he wasn't really around a whole lot at
the time anyway they were like what
would your mom do for a living my mom
was retired like there was like an
influx of cash I think like on paper at
that you said retired in in my mind your
dad's dating like a 68 year
old she had me old
no so she was she was just a house like
a a housewife you know what I mean uh
and he like sold the construction it's
all hairy and no one at this point now
when I start asking questions a decade
later two I heard you say he was in
construction we knew it was shady
already okay we knew there was some
shady Biz going on it was like I think
he had retired like I'm just going to do
this on the side like I have enough
money coming in for the next like 10
year I think there was like some sort of
buyout structure or something like that
I don't really know but um that when
they got divorced that all went belly up
and I think the company that he was with
kind of went belly up as well so he had
to like go he had to start over at you
know in his 30s again with three kids
divorced and my mom had to go back to
work my mom worked as a a lab tech in
hospitals and she worked third shift so
like she would leave at 3: and get back
at like midnight or 1:00 a.m. or
whatever uh so we were like raised it
was my brother myself and my sister
sister in that house like I mean you
know fighting and [__] there was no I
was I I feel like I've been on my own
since six like it was just like go my
brother's like I'm going out with my
friends I'm in the house I'm
skateboarding out I'm doing so I felt
like I was just there was very little
oversight looking back yeah um and my
dad like the blue collar and like I have
it now where it's like I don't want that
to become my life of like they live to
work they live to work and like I watch
watch it drive them crazy I watched like
they live and die
by what happened that day and like
there's no separation of life like there
was no like big Vacations or anything it
was like we would go down the Jersey
Shore that's where every dirt bag from
Philly goes yeah Maryland is Ocean City
yes we would but you're going for a week
we would go or a few days you're not
going you're not day tripping at least
like you do uh Pacific Ocean here no no
no you're going we would go get a motel
it would be my mom and my Aunt uh my mom
and my aunt who was also divorced or
remarried um we get one motel room for
[__] 12 of us yeah two two beds two B
15 kids [__] you know what I mean
they' give us there'd be 15 kids they
give us like 20 bucks and they go go on
the board wall for seven hours like feed
I was the youngest they were like make
sure he's fed don't get any fist fights
like protect him if he come if you don't
come back with him do not come back at
all type thing
um so but even then like we would go
down for like two or three days my dad
like I got to go back to work like he
would drive up and drive and I'm like
just [__] it was it consumed a small
bit like it consumed the family as like
same and my same thing with my stepdad
when my mom got remarried construction
worker cons owned his own construction
company consumed the family I guess my
mom has a type that I
say Irish construction workers yeah yeah
yeah yeah so wait when uh how long
before your mom gets remarried I don't
know man um like how old are you when
you remember him coming around young
maybe like three years like she didn't
you know there was nobody and then this
is the only she met this guy like there
was no like dating there was no like you
know revolving door of dudes coming in
uh it was just him and he was great he
was really good but like
also very same thing like Irish Catholic
construction worker drink and smoking
family that it's like there's no real
emotional expression at all like for the
longest time I we were referred to as
Denise's
kids that's terrible for like 20 years
20 years 20 years dude you're an adult
we were Denise's kids you're a gr I'd be
sitting there smoking sigs with them
Denise's kids are over there voting
right now dude I'd be 26 I'd come home
from New York I'm trying to be a
comedian and when be like having a Sig
and like a guy he knew like oh this is
Denise's kid you know youngest that's
what it was so it was very like him
never
Kevin this it would be this is Kevin
Denise's youngest you know always came
yeah it was always preface was this
[__] ain't
mine I don't [__] know him I ain't
never met this guy listen if he [__] up
talk to Denise talk to Denise talk to
Denise but he was very loving and but
like not it was just didn't couldn't
express it type thing you know what I
mean it was always there for us if we
needed did your dad and your stepdad get
along in the sense of let's keep it
copesthetic for the kids you know what I
mean like that was profession
professional it's a professional thing
what I call it and also like did your
dad and mom a little more than
professional or professional
professional okay it was professional it
was you know I'm sure they had fights
not in front of yeah it was never the
the dropoffs were always whatever it was
fine or like they would come to games
you know if there was some sort of
bigger game or something um that was
always I give them that it was never in
front of us ever uh and they would do
like a good tag team if need be if like
myself or my brother and my sister were
acting up it was like we they were a
united front in the parenting uh and my
dad my dad was great he was like you
know again like when he wasn't working
it was like very he was there or at
least around you know he was he was very
engaged did he remarry he remarried and
then got red divorced so I have two
younger brothers with him that I'm 10
years older and 16 years older wow and
my sister's like 16 years older and 21
years older than my two half Brothers
got it so it was but like my sister at
that point was already out of the house
and it was really just me like they were
in college or working or whatever so it
was really just me I was in high school
or whatever when they were born
um but like he was good my dad my dad
was great like never you know we never
wanted for anything he was always there
was he was very supportive of a lot of
stuff but then as we got older and we
were in like business together like wait
you went into business with your dad
yeah after he had already broken up his
family with like he he was working with
his four brothers none of them talk
anymore and then and then he came to my
brother I'm g go right to my my kids got
it you know what I mean so like it was
me my dad and my brother and that was
like it was a construction business
construction Tight money like you know
trying to cover doing are you doing like
buildings are you doing decks you doing
what are you doing it was commercial uh
mechanical Contracting so like heating
air conditioning plumbing and stuff like
that for like you know and is it Dian is
it Denise's
Sons Denise's boys Denise's boys yeah
that's what he called us these are
Denise's boys man that's a go that's my
first album Denise's
boy I just made my special Lefty son d
Denise's boys man yeah um
so uh that's when it got bad it got bad
between me and my brother it got bad
between my brother and my dad me and my
dad and that's kind of when it all fell
apart um other than that it was what
were the issues like stress who's in
charge who's you know it's like you got
three [__] lunatics in a room in an
office this big and there's the money's
tight and you're like what the you know
everybody's screaming and hooting and
hollering that goes back to like you
asked if me and Foley fight and we do
and like we we were talking like I
express myself by yelling at somebody
and I don't necessarily mean it but I'm
like there's emotion I got to get it out
let's yell at each other for 20 minutes
until we go oh okay I gotcha so that's
it was that but very when my brother
says Hey [__] face I don't walk away and
be like you're not going to talk to me
like that I turn around yeah that's oh
what the [__] oh he's got something he
wants to say to yeah so it's that's
where it's very like Fu face listen like
well I'm listening I'm all you got my
attention I'm
listen it's uh it was very that man and
it still is I had so like my mom was
like listen I've seen this business ruin
families like two of them multiple
families two of them right here under
her in our Circle you know what I mean
she's like I do not want [__] and this
is a test to my how great my mom is
she's like I do not want [__]
Thanksgiving to be weird
between you my two sons and she's like
do not and I was I was the second one in
my brother had already been doing it so
I was
like I'll I'll bow out if I feel like
this is getting to not if it's going to
change how we are in the future um and
then like we ended up fist fighting a
couple times me and my brother as adults
as business as business as as co-workers
Jesus boys are fight got Den's boys suck
can't take them nowhere fighting at the
fighting at the goddamn hola hands
waiting on three forklifts these guys
are over here we just sign the contract
we're fighting in the parking
lot who's got the paycheck we're [__]
fist fight was beating each other so how
did it when's the first time it came to
blows what happened I mean it did all
obviously all through childhood cuz I'm
bigger I've always I was always bigger
even though you're younger you've been
bigger we were like I was a bigger kid I
was a f bigger kids so like we were the
same weight and you know and I'm a I you
know as a comedian it's like I'm a sharp
tonged I can [__] I know what hurts
you and I'll get there quick type thing
and he's got a itchier trigger finger
than I have so it was like he'd say
something I'd snipe him once or twice
he'd get you know in his yeah he'd be
like who the [__] are you talking to I'm
like I'm not [__] afraid of you and
then we you know so it happened we were
also drinking a lot together I like he
was I was like I was probably like 20 3
or 24 he was like 27 we had like the
same group of friends we're hanging out
with our cousins so like we'd work there
was no separation of church and state at
that point it was like all right hey
we're leaving work we're going to go
shower we're going to meet everybody out
to go drinking and it's like you know
when you're that young and dumb and
you're adding booze that much alcohol to
it and tensions are high it'll just just
spilled over at some Irish pub in Philly
for the Irish Pub we are such [__]
dirt B is that really where it was it
was it was called the Irish
Pub dude I'm just put putting this
together now we are such Irish
Trash they Denise's boys are at it again
they're at the Irish Pub which one the
Irish Pub that's the name it's not even
like [__] you know McGrady's Irish
Pub it's just the Irish Pub oh
God man it's generational Irish
Trash just losing your [__] on each
other oh yeah just and it's like I don't
even know what's said it off it was
probably like I called him a [__] cuz
he didn't do a shot of you know Jameson
or something so then it just got he I
also wanted to get more into I had just
started doing comedy so I'm like all
right I want to get into it a little bit
more um so I uh I was like I'm I'm
bowing out that this was the last one
I'm you know what do we we gotten three
fist fights in two months like this
ain't this ain't great so I bowed out
and you know it kind of jolted our
relationship a little bit because it was
like you know uh it wasn't it was abrupt
like we didn't see it ending that way
like we you always think you're the
exception of the rule you're like well
my dad and his brother's fault my
stepdad and his brother's fault my
uncle's fault it's not going to happen
to us and then sure as [__] A year later
we're like we didn't even stand we
didn't even make it a year dude you know
what I mean um so that hindered our
relationship a little bit just like we
weren't as close we also weren't working
together we weren't hanging out as much
I was really focused on comedy at the
time um so so he's just left with your
now so he's just left with my dad and so
they don't dissolve the business they're
going to keep running they're going to
keep going it's
been just Den's boy they crossed the S
off the [__] off the
Vans I mean y'all had Vans that's big
time I had some van we had we had a
[__] this we had this green Dodge Ram
2500 or something with jacked up we
bought it a used aued one the extended
that's the kind we used to use for like
wrestling they would take like two of
those and we would take us around blue
one MH like YMCA Camp Vans yeah yeah
yeah but this was like the this was the
pickup version this is a huge pickup
version We called it the green monster
and this thing was in the shop every 3
hours dude it was like you had to and we
would put such an illegal size load of
whatever we were putting on it it was
like if it wasn't hanging six feet off
the back of that bed we weren't even try
you know what I mean you're not even
working why' you even get why you put
your boots on we ain't taking two trips
that's for damn sure that's Denise's
boy's motto that's the mot and the
famous last
words making two trips we ain't coming
back
[Laughter]
baby that and the famous last words of
Denise's boys construction company was
shaking something on the back of the
truck going that ain't going
nowhere next thing you know you're on 95
South [__] running down the
shoulder dude that happened to be oh you
give me a flashback right now so we used
to go crabbing with my dad I love CRA we
just did it a couple weeks ago in the
Jersey Shore I love crabing we used to
go crabing and we made our own Trot Line
we had a 100 yard trot line that we
would run and we had a nice uh bass boat
Little John boo aluminum and we would
take uh we go to the Y River in Maryland
W the Y River and we dropped the bull
lips and it's bups we're using for bait
we drop it in we crab all day but my dad
had made this rig that a friend of him a
friend of his showed him where you take
out the where the the eyeh holes for the
ores you put like a 2x4 across with
bolts that go in so they go in sure and
then you have um a a spool a rope spool
at the end and that's when you just pick
it up and as you move through it gently
comes up and down right so we're driving
home we're you know it's an early day
you're getting up at like 4 in the
morning you're getting down there an
hour and a half drive you want to get
right on the water when the sun's up
and we're driving home and I'm sleeping
in the back seat and I hear my dad holy
[__] oh my God Ryan and just I have two
brothers Ryan Ryan I go what the [__] he
goes the whole 2x4 thing flew up out of
the boat it's all over the highway go
get it I said what are you talking about
go get it's it's Interstate 50 yeah the
car is shaking as
yeah be careful he's just up there in
the be careful he ain't coming out to
help no one's coming and I'm out there
dragging all the the whole thing being
run over and shattered I was like holy
[__] Jesus Christ dude it's we tow our
boat with a
1979 Dodge Aspen station wagon bro we
towed our boat with a station wagon
limited edition tinted windows wood
panel dude if you're launching a boat
with tinted windows and it's station
wagon you're having a good day P.S this
is for your are you garbage people that
same station wagon was one of my cousins
wedding limos
oh you can't make it up wedding limo
they pulled and then when we turned 16
my dad's like I'll buy that [__]
thing let these let these boys drive a
big old station wagon around and get
used to it yeah damn so funny dude ever
have an early meeting fall on a Monday
morning if you have then you know that
some things just don't mix like oil and
water our bodies don't absorb CBD oil
well so when you reach for oilbased CBD
products you could be absorbing as low
as 6% of what's on the label next Evo
Naturals developed a proprietary water
soluble form of CBD clinically tested
multiple times which has proven to work
faster and absorb four times better so
you can stay calmer or sleep better
during this stressful time of year I've
noticed that after a long day of working
at the studio or even traveling on tour
next Evo CBD is great for helping me
relax and unwind quicker it's not well
known but CBD isn't actually an oil but
other companies often dissolve it in oil
because it's a cheap and easy way to
make products like tinctures and gummies
don't waste your time with oilbased CBD
that might not work upgrade to better
natural solutions from next Evo go to
next evo.com and use promo code honeydew
to get 25% off that's 25% off at NE X
t.com promo code honeydew this podcast
is sponsored by better help whether or
not your family gives gifts during the
holidays you get to Define how you give
to yourself and the holidays are a great
time to do that so whether it's by
starting therapy going easier on
yourself during the tough moments or
treating yourself to a day of complete
rest remember to give yourself some love
this holiday season if you're thinking
of starting therapy give better help a
try you know we always talk about about
therapy here being positive we talk
about it you know working out your body
and working out your mind so if you're
even thinking about it I'm telling you
it's a good thing to do all right it's
entirely online it's designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with the
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge in the
season of giving give yourself what you
need with better help visit
betterhelp.com honeydo to
to get 10% off your first month that's
better help
hp.com honeydo if I asked you how many
subscriptions you have would you be able
to list all them and how much you're
paying if you would asked me this
question before I started using rocket
money I would have said yes but let me
tell you I would have been dead wrong I
couldn't believe how many I had that I
wasn't even using some I hadn't touched
for months it's just money out the
window rocket money is a personal
finance app that finds and cancels your
unwanted subscriptions monitors your
spending and helps lower your bills I
can see all my subscriptions in one
place and if I see something I don't
want I can cancel it with a tap I never
have to get on the phone with customer
service and that is the best part
they'll even try to get you a refund for
the last couple of months of wasting
money and negotiate to lower your bills
for you by up to 20% all you have to do
is take a picture of your bill and
Rocket money takes care of the rest
rocket money has over 5 million users
and has helped save its members and a
Aver of $720 a year with over 500
million in canceled subscriptions stop
wasting money on things you don't use
cancel your unwanted subscriptions by
going to Rocket money.com honeydo that's
rocket.com honeydo rocket
money.com honeydo now let's get back to
the do all right so so brother uh Den
very close with we're all very close
except my then my that so Denise's son
Denise's boy is now working with his dad
now working with with Dad that goes
south shortly after I can imagine maybe
a year and even then and like I'm in the
middle of it cuz it's like they're not
talking to each other but but is he is
your brother starting to lean more
toward you now like man is opening back
up are you repairing your relationship
we were it was never bad it just wasn't
what it was we were so close this is
what I love about especially Irish
families you say it was never bad you
had three fist fights that Ain bad where
I come from what are we doing in a year
in a year year in a year not in your
lifetime in a year it was a rough year
we were have quarterly fist fight we
were facing a recession copper prices
were through the roof margins were there
junkies down and Kensington are robbing
us blinding God
there can't keep it on a
truck oh God that ain't going nowhere
crackhead [__] pulls it all off
Famous Last Words man oh God damn and
you never feel more confident you have a
Sig in your mouth and you're shaking I
ain't going nowhere H in we're
good so that it goes south with them and
I was trying to mediate it a little bit
you know
um and uh it didn't it didn't work then
they that was the last I was on the
phone with my dad trying to figure it
out and it's also like you call me in to
be the mediator the guy you know the guy
who's already you know escorted off the
property assaults
um and that you know who we should call
Kevin up here Kevin Kevin got a real
level who Kevin it's one of the n's boys
the youngest
one youngest
boy um but I do I do have a thing that
like me and my brother are closer
because of that exch like I I guess
that's the only way we know how to we
knew how to do it at the time we're way
better but it's like that's just yeah
that's what you grow up knowing and how
everything is dealt with yeah that's why
I'm terrible at arguing and I've tried
to get better at I can't get I can't
come out of the gate with like shut the
[__] up and listen to me cuz that's not
going to let people listen yeah nobody
listens nobody listens you've
immediately offended everybody in the
room yeah um but uh so then yeah then
that was honestly the
last conversation I had with my dad was
on the phone really and that was in
[__] what year is it now man that was
probably 23 yeah it was probably
2013 yeah so you haven't communicated at
all in 10 years I saw him at a WWA not
too long
ago that is so [__] pet and I [__]
iced him we walked yeah we walked right
each other he saw you he's crazy yeah
and we were like I was like I was like
you did he say your name no just [__]
I was like you want I was like let's see
who's it was a game of chicken I'm like
let's see who crazy how what was your
when did you realize he was in there
when you were did you see him I was
walking out and I saw him getting out of
the car of the Wawa and you walk right
and I was just like well let's you know
I you know I was nervous like I I'd be
lying if I said I wasn't like oh my God
like obviously yeah it's your father you
know anybody that close to you for your
whole life a charge of emotions comes up
and I'm like what do I do do I hug I
want to just honestly at the bottom I
just want to just [__] hug him and be
like I love you you're my dad but um we
hard-headed Irish Yaks so it's like but
also like so many of us have had to be
the parents in relation and like that's
a moment right there where a parent
should just be like I don't give a [__]
if you're a grown man put this aside
like let me go get my [__] s MTO
sandwich real quick I'm going get my waa
sandwi my coffee and then we'll [__]
we'll have a s look at the truck or
whatever you know what I mean but that
didn't you know that didn't happen and
uh I talked to my mom about I tried a
year ago you said this is maybe two
years ago two years ago and he never
texted or tried to reach out after that
like hey man not after that no there was
one
call of in the Middle where I was like
you know I kind of found out who I was
like you know I was just realizing who I
was as a person as a man probably around
like you know early 30 mid late 20s or
whatever I was in New York I was work
comedy was going like okay I was making
Headway at least of like I'm you know
and I'm like oh I am who I am and I
started dating my now wife and I was
just like you know just trying to like
make sense of who I am and everything I
was like you know what I got to [__]
I think I texted him on Father's Day
Happy Father's Day and then I think he
called
me and uh I was at work I couldn't
answer and I called him back and we
spoke for like a couple of minutes and
it was very like hey when you're back
he's like I hear you're in New York you
know kind of just gave him like a
rundown so he's never seen or you don't
know if he's ever seen you live um I
think he might have saw me live once
when I was living before this so like
when I first started but not since you
blown up uhuh no no or that you know of
no I you think he's the type of dude
that would buy a ticket slip in the back
watch never say anything I don't think
so I think he knows like when we go back
to Philly I think he knows that's like
Behind Enemy Lines like my all my mom's
like like I said they're one of nine I
have like 35 first cousins just on that
side so it's like they all come and like
everybody's so we're so all so close
everybody's so supportive so like I
think he be he my he knows like my mom's
going and he doesn't talk to my brother
or my sister so it's like I think he
knew he would know it's like so it's not
just you he's not talking he he he talks
to like three people left I think I
don't even know you know I know he
doesn't he's got a rough had a rough
relationship with his brothers and
friends and how old is he
now late
60s probably you know anything about him
you sorry I interrupt you said after
that interaction or non- interaction you
talked to your mom about and she was
like listen you know she's like
I've been with this you know i' I've
been through the ringer with this with
she's like I I don't want you I she's
like I'm so happy yeah talk to him I
just also I don't want you to get hurt
like don't get your hopes up she's like
I think you'll realize that relationship
is what you make it like not don't wait
for him to text and like she's like if
you're okay with you reaching out when
you come home and you go get a beer with
them or whatever she's like that's great
and I kind of did a test I was like you
know what I'm not going to I'm not going
to reach out I'm going to
see when he reaches that and he never
did so I'm like all right you know um
but yeah it's tough I don't know we were
so close and he was a great dad it's
like you did I'm like I'm like you
[__] idiot you did all the hard work
I'm saying you came [__] you
spent all the money you help pay for
college you [__] he was there all the
time I can't say really one bad thing
about him raising me then but now I'm
like I don't you know it's like running
a business running a business with the
boys
with Denise's with Denise's boys not
even his kids they're not even his kids
yeah in in the joke either his sons
aren't his sons it's Denise's
boys all right so tell me goad sorry
yeah but in that my stepdad's around I
was just about to say tell me about your
relationship with your stepfather so you
meet him pretty young pretty young seven
eight you know something like that and
around there I'm so bad this show like
doing Ru garbage now has made me go back
and look at my life through a different
lens of you know all these things and
hearing your stories and stuff like that
I'm like oh [__] like it's like Sparks
all these synapses dark going like I
forgot about that and I think I might
have been like a sociopath as a kid like
I'm not emotional like Foley my co-host
is so emotional it's like so I could if
I could do this and get back and all all
of this and that I'm like [__] serial
killer like it's in there but I do it's
like it goes back to that thing of like
don't Revel in the problem [__] put
your head down grab a sixpack on the way
home from work and [__] on to the
next day there's a there's a job to be
done the the car has to move forward
type thing um so it's like I remember my
dad being like yeah we don't have time
to like yeah we're at a funeral whatever
it is we don't have to like [__] move
on and you're like [__] you know um
which now I'm like realizing there's a
[__] ton of [__] up emotions in me
that I've never looked at over the past
[__] 37 years welcome to the honey
dude man it's tough it's tough I used to
think I'm like my parents divorce never
affected me once and then I got in like
a real serious relationship and I'm like
oh it's like well then my relationship
now with my wife is my first like really
true she said I need you to sit down I
got to tell you something you're like oh
[__] I was like yeah this ain't good um
but then I remember I was having a
conversation with how we were fighting
about money it was before the podcast
took off and God bless we'll get back to
my step that but God bless her she moved
in from Germany she's German she moved
from Germany to the US to be with me I
had been no money oh wow no money she
moved there she moved here 3 days later
I checked my debit card and like I
miscalculated my check my checking
account statement and I was like
$2,800 in the hole like dude to [__]
overdraft charges overdraft charges DD B
don't [__] around it's their money and
they want it
now that [__] JG
Wentworth and I remember sitting there
like I'm such I'm like this woman just
uprooted her life and moved here to be
with me so I could Chase my stupid dream
of Comedy I have no money comedy
probably made me 800 bucks last year
like and I'm sitting here looking down
the barrel three days later of and I
told her I was like I can't do this I'm
like if you want to leave leave I'm like
I wasn't able to make it three days and
I'm in I'm I'm in more debt than I've
ever been in in my life um but she's
been great and and but we was talking to
her one time we were talking about money
and it's that anger thing I was sitting
there and she's like what I try to live
in like this we'll figure it out work it
just I just keep moving forward don't
stop and look at the problems and she's
like but how are you going to do this
and I'm like I don't know we were
fighting and I was just like I wanted it
she made me spaghetti and I wanted to
throw this spagh I was so just so
frustrated like and there's nowhere and
I wanted to throw the plate of spaghetti
against the wall and I'm like man that
is you can't come back from that the
second that in your house you can no
even then it might be even in my house
growing up be like who's cleaning that
up you just broke a dish BR who's pay
for to steal one from the diner now see
Mom see he's an [__] I've been
telling
you but it was one of those of like [__]
and that those kind of moments made me
realize of like oh I do have crazy anger
and you know volatile emotions that I
need to uh to work on but um all that my
stepdad was involved at a distance
through all of that like while my dad
was raising us and you know co-parenting
with my mom or whatever my stepdad was
there like kind of in the
background when we were really young he
was great like he I mean he was dude he
was a [__] he was from the suburbs
like born and raised in the suburbs when
they was like country so he was like a
hick like cowboy boots dude he he drove
he built and drove stock cars no [__] uh
as like a hobby with like his hillbilly
boys where like that was their weekend
they'd go down and they all their money
with a tinker and then he'd go race and
crash right over away and be like ah
next week we're going to get him that
[__] never finished a
race never dude smoked Winston's drank
hores lights like the cool and he' be
like oh I got a boat he's like I have a
wave runner cuz he was like this he was
like he was making some money and he was
a single guy no kids he's calling a wave
runner a boat or no he had a boat and a
w
let's let's hold on is a two-seater
the grabing off the back of the cowak
Just Fish
all drive
drive but um he was great he was really
great he he was like you know if my mom
was Jordan he was pipping he was like in
the back not in the Limelight was like
I'll step in when I need to step in he
very rarely ever tried to uh like
discipline us like he really knew his
role in that of like cuz he knew like if
we would fight back or something it
could get to my he knew I'm not making
this any messier than it already is they
have a pretty good working system I'll
fall back and you know I'm just here
to play with Denise yes I'm just yes den
I'm Denise's new Den's new
husband that's all I and I'm hanging out
here all that other mess with these dirt
bag kids let them figure that out with
I'll be in charl yeah yeah
I'll are running this weekend we're
going to be down there in Flemington
Flemington New Jersey that's where he
would race Flemington New Jersey
man um but he was great loved him he was
fantastic all through uh all through
childhood then uh and we once I got a
little older we would bump heads a
little more kind of thing and it was
also cuz like me and my brother were
[__] idiots you know it's like oh
[__] you know [__] you like we were so
close to my dad like yeah you're not my
dad now we never said that but it was
kind of like sometimes like shut the
[__] out get out of here like I'm doing
whatever the [__] I want to do type
thing um and then he got sick D they
were like Cowboys dude he was like you
couldn't [__] kill the him and his
brothers and his dad they had like
cancer like between three of them like
15 times no dude he got diagnosed with
Stage 4B lung cancer what is that
there's a B on like you're right at five
right heard of a letter on they were
like you there's nothing we can do it's
a rap it's there's genuinely nothing we
can do like [__] and this
was seven years ago something like that
we're like what the [__] man this is
crazy and then it just healed itself it
just I swear to god dude it just all the
cancer just like he did radiation and
[__] like whatever but like they were
like we'll try but like we're really
just buying some time here this is
inoperable there's nothing we can do and
he lived and it just one day the doctor
went in and there was like he's like
it's all just now scar tissue like it's
there's no cancer left in your lungs
it's just Scar Tissue I've never heard
anything like that either nobody nobody
did we were like what the [__] like what
the [__] is this so then he gets back on
the heaters obviously like he feel he's
[__] bionic man dude he can't hold
this guy back what are you talking about
he's back on the heaters and this is
when it's like what we're smoking I'm
smoking so we're at Family parties and
like at that point my mom's like
everybody's done [__] smoking you
know no more smoking
but then it's like because of him she's
like I'm I you know he's I'm not going
was she smoking as well no no but like
my me my brother and my and my stepdad
were and he's like sh it was bad it was
rough like he was Doom and Gloom the
radiation was the hair it's you know I
mean it's you know a lot of people know
it's not a pretty [__] scene but he
weathered the
storm so then we're like all right we're
you know he starts smoking so we're
smoke we're like hiding behind cars and
[__] family parties fu
oh here she comes [__] hold these for me
like you know what I mean real [__]
and like you feel bad I'm like but it's
also like it was this weird way we
bonded you know what I mean we'd be at a
family party and like we didn't talk
that much was a very quiet dude like
head down just did his own thing so like
you'd make eyes with him at the at the
party I'm like yeah let's go I'm like
I'm you know was like the way I we
bonded and talked and you would get some
conversation of like how's comedy like
that's when we so I felt bad I'm like
man I'm giving this guy [__] sigs she
would get smoke breaks yeah get smoke to
learn more about him and VI Vera that
was the extent of our real like
communication and dialogue was over sigs
and
beer and then
um then he had some liver issues like
two years ago you know due to just
smoking and drinking a lot uh beat that
beat that the doctor's
like yeah these numbers are insane that
you're reporting back like they were
like whatever the the stat was it was
like most people are a 10 you're a one
wow and then it was
like oh now you're a nine you're you're
an 11 it was like he was back to normal
thing it was like doom and glue it was
like that was it again we're like he
can't [__] kill this guy and then he
got can he got lung cancer again right
after that and was like ready to fight
it and was like I'm
going you know CU he couldn't drive so
he made the choice not to fight it no
he's like I'm fighting it he's like I'm
strapped in he's like let's [__] go
like you can't you can't get me we're
doing this and this was in the beginning
this was the end of last year how old
was he he was young man here
uh [__] 50 in his 50s 58 maybe
something like that young he was younger
than my mom and uh he was like I'm ready
and like he cuz he couldn't drive
afterwards so we had to get him like he
was going to take Uber like he got a car
service of like okay um cuz he had to
drive like 90 minutes or something my
mom's like I can't make it every day and
he didn't want another burden on my mom
so he's like I got this car service
that's going to drive me Monday
Wednesday and Friday back and forth
whatever whatever um and then right
before he just woke up in middle of the
night coughing bad and then passed at
the house like pretty immediately yeah
they were like yeah yeah my mom called
911 oh man the cops had come you know
the EMS came and they worked on them
there for a little bit and just didn't
couldn't get him um so he he passed and
then just like as as [__] stupid as
we are we're at his four his lunch in
like we go for the the funeral and then
we go to like the lunch in to his
favorite bar like you know what this is
how we're going to honor this guy who's
you know essentially you know smoked and
dranked himself they don't do the Irish
no no I want I want that though I want
that yeah I want to be on a pool table I
learned about that from The Wire when
they that guy I didn't know but that is
a thing that's a traditional thing I I
think cops do I think they used to do it
back in the day yeah it's like an Irish
I don't think Nobody Does it anymore I
don't think you're allowed to have a
body walk in until everybody shows
up he's put him on top of the Bud Lights
nobody's drinking him
anymore um and then dud so were there
and like we there and his favorite he
loved uh absolute and time big vodka
tonic guy so we're doing
shots of absolute to this guy who like
drinking obvious I think in the end got
him and I'm like the we are idiots like
you're drinking gasoline to kill yeah
I'm like what are we doing like you
smoking too oh crank dude cranking
heaters we were smoking so many we had
my wife go on a Sig
run dude it was we're idiot like we
can't I'm like I stepped outside myself
I'm like what the [__] are we doing here
but I don't know it's like there's
something to that life of like
this is what we enjoy this is what we do
this is who we are and like it is what
it is and that's you know I don't know
is a very like uh sad but romantic thing
of like this is I shared a lot of times
with him like this and this is how we
bonded whether right or wrong but it's
like this is what it was and this is how
we're celebrating his passing or
whatever so it was
like it was just this weird thing I'm
like we're sitting here doing the thing
that [__] got this [__] and
we're like
twice and we're like celebrating like
you know I got we got shots of absolute
and [__] Beres going in the hands but
it was uh it was tough but it's also
like one of those things to of like it's
made our family closer a little bit now
that like you know it's like I I come
back now that my
mom you know now that he's passed like I
come back and see my mom a lot more
we're doing a lot more stuff as a family
just cuz like it it shook me of like
[__] you know this is you know it just
made things more real of like like how
much time do you have left with all
these people and it's like do I like we
work very hard and it's you know it's
not I'm not laying bricks or anything
but it's like it's a you know it's a
very hectic schedule comedy and you you
you give up a lot of time to places and
stuff like that and I've gotten way
better of going like yeah I don't want
to do that like I'm not putting in for
spots or like I'm not doing this and I
want my day I want you know I'm going
down to have lunch with my family and
like really making that effort yeah and
it's like cuz it's like I don't want to
look back back in you know [__] 15
years and be like I was doing cuz I had
like a 1:00 a.m. spot I decided not to
go to the the family party or something
like that so I'm like and it's that
weird thing is like you try in comedy
you do everything I'll take everything
I'm asking to do everything I'll do
whatever you have does it pay no money
anything I'm I'm in and now I'm like oh
[__] that like I don't I don't you know
not that I don't care but it's like it
shift my focus a lot so it's been the
past year has been a uh you know
figuring stuff out type thing in a good
way in a good way and what about you and
your brother you guys we're chilling man
we're better than we've ever been
honestly like I never think you should
work with family I've I've watched it
just destroy families uh you know and
it's just not it never works and like I
have a bit about it but it's like yeah
when the family's good like if your
family owns [__] you know Apple great
yeah I'm sure it's fun because you're
splitting up billions of dollars when
you're like a brick layer or you're
painting houses and money's tight and no
one really knows how to run a business
and you're like it's a [__] it's it's a
nightmare especially in those blue
collar families money's always tight
always home improvement's getting laid
off money's tight I mean when my dad
died I didn't even know about living
will in a trust or oh no that's any of
that they're like did you have any like
like no my dad was 42 I don't think he
thought he was going to die but still so
I went and made sure that I got that
[__] done yeah for my daughter uh no
life insurance you know I made sure we
got the life insurance that kind of [__]
um that's how it's affected me like I
still have that blue collar uh blue
collar mentality and work Hustle but I
want to make sure I'm doing that [__] in
the white collar world yeah you no
that's so true you know I'm saying apply
that hustle and that work ethic to this
[__] thing over don't stay here
that's what and like that's what we do
like we work like like you know we do
four episodes a week we tour like crazy
we guess on a [__] ton of pot like it's
is we apply that blue collar like I mean
what I was working with my family I was
digging ditches like I was literally in
I was digging six foot holes like that
was part of my job because it was like
well we can't hire somebody I you know I
was working in the office during the day
and then at night we were digging
ditches so it's like yeah just go work
it's like that thing you're just digging
it just work go go go but I'm not
digging ditches now we're doing you know
a white collar in industry I used to
have so many people in high school and
college want me to do stuff I'm like I
have to work and they would get so mad
like you're always working I'm like you
have parents yeah yeah I don't have any
I got do this [__] work I need clothes
dude are you going to give me the money
to get by today all right then I'm going
to [__] have to go to work yeah it's
uh it is a very like feast or famine
thing I've learned of like that blue
collar Lifestyle the money comes
in and most people people aren't like
I've had friends like I grew up in like
a pretty affluent area because like they
they had that money for like a year
bought the place and then that was my
mom was like we're keeping this [__]
place I don't care what bills are behind
like we're keeping the [__] mortgage
and my dad would pay child support to my
mom and that money would just go she's
like that's paying the mortgage like all
that [__] everything else she just put
on a credit card um and like I was it
was weird because like I was friends
with the blue collar workers it would be
like all my friends dads
owned a construction company or a
landscaping company or like did like
auto sales or something like that
somebody's got a roll back in mix
exactly and all like then but we were
like there was all like the it was like
doctors and lawyers kids and you're like
oh like we just culturally not that like
we were friends with them and stuff but
it was like we I bonded with the other
kids who's and everybody's money was up
and down houses getting foreclosed on
where you know one year they're put put
on an addition the next year they're
taking the [__] house away it's like
dude how did you not see that coming one
year you know what like dude like nobody
was planning six months ahead of like
they go oh it's like sports stars
they're like I made a million dollars
this year I'm gonna make a million
dollars for the rest of my life you're
like n dude you got five years to make
that money and you got to make it last
30 years that's right but uh that's what
I you know I'm trying to do now but I'm
I'm so hardwired to make bad decisions
financially like I just you know I'm
just hardwired to do it do you have a
business manager no you got to get a
business man I know I had nothing we
just we're just running and gunning dude
it's somewhere I mean this is the first
year my taxes are paid I'm like I and I
still got money left over I'm like y
we're chilling we're chilling D I'm the
smartest guy in the world but yeah it's
like I'm trying to learn from the the
flaws of of the people before me but I
don't know we we'll see what happens
dude you're doing great and this is this
is a great episode thank you man thank
you for doing this and this is your
first time here I ask everybody their
first time after everything we've talked
about today advice you would give to
16-year-old Kevin Ryan oh Jesus Christ
um I would say let
go a lot of anxiety is you know just
worry I would worry and worry and worry
and worry and it's like when you're in
your teens you think that's the most
you're like I don't want to turn 20 I
don't want to be in my TW I don't want
to graduate college I want these years
to last forever and it's like
I'm 37 and these are the best years of
my life you know what I mean like I did
love all those times and the kids and
being all that stuff like I loved the
[__] out of that and there's so many
great moments but like I would be like
ah [__] we're going to be 20 and then we
got to get jobs and then we got to do
this and do that it's like I held it too
tight and I maybe not enjoyed just
[__] relax things will fall into
place at some time and if they don't
they don't and that's just is what it is
type thing just accept a little bit yeah
I love it thank you it's been a pleasure
to have one of Denise's boys really has
um free
estimates we ain't coming
back um plug and promote everything
again yeah uh at Kevin Ryan comedy on
all social media our live shows are a
very good time it's a very fun live show
me and Foley both co-headline then we
play a with the crowd um the podcast
we've had you twice we've had so many
people we've had Lou Tom sagora bird a
bunch Norman whoever uh Shane Gillis
check them out it's a good time hope you
like it great uh as always ryanr
docomond CER on all social media come
see me on tour tickets on my website
we'll talk to youall next
[Music]
[Applause]
week
[Music]
a